all right are you guys excited
yes okay tatum full out we're the only
team singing live we need a sound check
we don't have an unlimited amount of
time we have 10 minutes and we have a
lot to do
full out look at your center sing big
dance big do what you got to do
come on girls
shake it down feathers
come on let me hear you shake your tail
feathers do it right
shake it shake it baby
[Music]
that sound check the energy was just a
little bit low something was weird
[Music]
i'm gonna go up there
if they're not singing or what's going
on
[Applause]
[Music]
is happening they do not have their
heads in the game right now
okay stop kaya i just know you can sing
better
kyah you're the first member of the
group don't ever forget it
brooklyn
i don't know if it's in your head what
happened yesterday but it's a new day
it's a new day i feel like you're
tiptoeing around a few things jojo and i
gave these girls an awesome song an
awesome dance a fabulous set we got to
do a sound check
i'm nervous because
maybe we expected too much kinley and
tiny t sound good she's carrying this
group right now can we ask yes if we
could i would take everyone's off and
only let her sing but we can't do that
she said kinley's carrying this whole
group and if she got to cut brooklyn and
kaya
kenley will sing the whole thing
[Music]
you